the opening scene is set in the year
1946 where a family consisting of a
father mother and daughter is peacefully
sleeping in their beachfront home at the
stroke of midnight the father awakens
and climbs down the water tank located
in their backyard amidst a heavy
rainstorm as he Ventures down he is
suddenly attacked by an unseen creature
prompting him to scream in excruciating
pain despite his efforts to climb out of
the tank the creature pulls him inside
resulting in his
that's what happens you gotta keep those
things clean the scene then shifts to
the year 1978 in Oakland California
introducing us to a man named Ben along
with his wife Jules and their
ten-year-old daughter Rhea they run a
pet shop selling a variety of animals
one evening as they prepare to close the
shop an old lawyer named Amos Tilbury
walks into their shop bringing them some
shocking news Amos informs them about a
property owned by Ben's mother in
Hobbits Bay Oregon after his father's
passing here it is revealed that Ben is
none other than the son of the man from
the opening scene furthermore Amos
discloses that Ben's father and sister
didn't die in a car accident as Bennett
believed rather they mysteriously
disappeared around their beach house in
Oregon regardless they both passed away
before Ben's birth so he never got to
meet them the attorney also presents Ben
with a key to the beach house and
provides its location Ben and Jules are
surprised with all these Revelations but
they decide to visit the Inherited
property the next morning the family
packs their necessary belongings and
sets off for Oregon following a map they
exit the highway and make their way
through the woods only to discover a
massive fallen tree blocking their path
as a result they continue the remainder
of their Journey on foot after a bit of
walking they eventually reach the
abandoned house which is now completely
overgrown with plants they unlock the
door and step into the dusty interior
which appears to still be usable shortly
after the family heads to the backyard
where they are welcomed by the beautiful
scenery of their Bay they also locate
the water tank and Ben explains that
these types of tanks were once used to
collect rainwater or if you're lucky
mischievous naked skinny-dipping young
folk he then proceeds to investigate the
inside and learns that it's more like a
cave however he finds nothing but a
lantern which his father had used in the
opening scene afterwards the family
starts cleaning the house the best they
can they also bring some camping
equipment from their car indicating that
they have decided to stay at the house
for some days now later that evening the
couple goes through some photographs and
documents which they found while
cleaning the house many of them include
newspaper clippings related to The
Mysterious disappearance of Ben's father
and sister moreover they also find Ben's
mother's diary in which she has
recounted his father's Vanishing
stormy night and his sister's subsequent
disappearance five days later on the
same night Reya is trying to sleep in
her room when she hears a strange noise
coming from outside shortly after she
observed some movement beneath her bed
causing her to become frightened due to
this she hurries to her parents room and
informs them that something is trying to
get inside Ben and Jules then proceed to
check the entire house separately and
during her search Jules also hears
ominous sounds the sound leads her to
the backyard but she finds nothing there
she then turns around only to startled
by Ben whoa honey I gotcha believing
that the sound is nothing they walk back
to their room and sleep the next morning
Jules wakes up to see her husband trying
to fix the damaged parts of the house
including the generator a little while
later Ben Ventures down into the water
tank and inspects the pipes he then
adjusts the valve and confirms that
they're working before exiting the tank
Ben makes a discovery A peculiar
creature lying on the ground he brings
it inside the house and shows it to his
wife despite her expertise as an animal
specialist Jules is unable to identify
the creature and she has never seen such
a species in her life you haven't that's
an easy one it's a Polly pulp after a
brief examination she speculates that it
might be amphibian larva and suggests
that they take it home for further study
meanwhile Reya is playing with her dog
in the backyard when her attention is
drawn to the water tank peering inside
she is horrified to witness a large
creature moving within it prompting her
to scream benad Jules rushed to her side
but just like before they find nothing
inside the tank their conversation is
seen interrupted by the arrival of a
woman named Mariel tingi who is a local
broker sent by Amos she offers her
assistance in selling the property
explaining that she already has a
potential buyer eager to finalize the
transaction promptly the couple has
taken aback by the proposed selling
price which is much higher than they had
anticipated although they are pleased
with the offer they decide to take some
time before making a final decision
given their limited knowledge of the
area they inquire about the property's
history from Muriel in response she
shares that the land has been the
subject of rumors about being cursed
according to her the local people in the
region believed that a devastating
tsunami struck the area several
centuries ago leading to the belief that
the land is cursed I didn't know
tsunamis could do that by the time their
conversation concludes it is already
dark so Marielle returns to her car to
depart however her vehicle becomes stuck
in the mud prompting her to exit and
investigate just then she's attacked by
a mysterious creature and dragged deep
into the forest her screaming sounds
reached jules's ears so she heads
downstairs to check the little girl is
startled to see a shadowy figure outside
the kitchen window prompting her to
scream once again Ben rushes down baby
stop screaming now and checks the window
but finds nothing Jules desperately
wishes to leave the place self
benassures her that he will contact
Mariel the next day the following
morning Ben finds that the tap water is
completely filthy as a result he heads
down to the water tank to investigate
the issue there he discovers that a
piece of cloth is clogging one of the
pipes and also finds a dead raccoon
floating in the water he brings the
corpse out and shows it to his wife
convincing her that the creature their
daughter spotted the previous night was
likely the raccoon later in the day Ben
decides to visit a nearby gas station to
refill their car's gas while driving
through the woods he comes across
Mariel's abandoned car curious he begins
to search the area for any clues and
spots blood stains on the ground as he
follows the trail he's shockingly
discovers Mariel's mutilated body
terrified he rushes back to his car and
immediately contacts the police for help
back at the beach house Jules notices
the water tank hatch has been left open
she descends the stairs and notices
water spilled in various spots on the
floor she then grabs a bunch of keys and
enters an adjacent room where she
discovers another diary bearing Ben's
mother's handwriting within its Pages
Jules finds an account of the horrifying
experiences that Ben's mother endured in
the house and the reason why she kept
the truth hidden from bad it turns out
there are several terrifying creatures
residing inside the water tank they were
the ones that killed Ben's father and
sister when his mother found out about
it she immediately packed her belongings
and left the house meanwhile his Jules
continues reading the diary she hears
footsteps from outside concerned for her
daughter she decides to check on her but
the door seems to have been locked from
outside as a result Jules promptly
breaks a window and hurries upstairs to
Raya on the other hand Ben rushes back
to his family and is relieved to find
them safe they share their respective
Discovery span reveals about Mariel's
lifeless body while Jules discloses the
contents of his mother's diary she
requests that they immediately leave the
place but Ben persuades her to stay
assuring her that the police are on
Route and he wants to see them get eaten
because that's what they're gonna that
they're gonna die in the meantime he
decides to venture back into the woods
for reasons unknown before long a police
officer arrives at the scene and drops
by Mariel's car he then proceeds to
conduct a search of the area but finds
nothing amiss as a result of this he
returns to his vehicle and it is at this
moment he senses a presence behind him
it is a massive slimy reptilian creature
with long and sharp teeth before the
officer can react with a shot the
creature attacks him and drags him deep
into the woods Ben happens to witness
this horrifying scene from a distance
and runs back to his family he tells his
wife what happened and emphasizes that
they have to somehow survive the night
as the creatures only appear in the dark
in the next scene Ben decides to create
a makeshift bomb using leftover gas and
kerosene he wants to destroy the
creature's Nest within the water tank
Jules attempts to dissuade him citing
the extreme risk involved but Ben
insists that it is the only way out for
their survival trust me honey nothing's
safer than blowing up the house he
instructs his family to secure
themselves in a room while he gathers
the necessary materials before
descending into the water tank upon
heading inside the cave-like structure
then ignites the makeshift bombed and
hurries to exit however the bomb
detonates far more rapidly than he
anticipated with no such big effect
instead the sound of the bomb alerts the
creatures prompting them to launch an
attack on him then the latest and
greatest candidate for the Darwin Awards
engages in a desperate struggle against
the creatures and somehow manages to
emerge from the tank but he's brutally
injured in this process in the meantime
Jules and Reya hear a forceful banging
on the door Jules cautiously opens the
door and to her relief she discovers
that it's their dog Archie a short while
later there is another bang on the door
and this time with more power Jules
realizes that it is the creature so she
tries to block the door with a cupboard
however another creature breaches the
room through a window and drags Raya
outside and down into the water tank
seeing this Jules rushes down to save
her daughter all the while noticing the
Gravely injured Ben lying on the ground
I shouldn't have done the bomb thing
honey recognizing that he's in no
condition to fight anymore Jules takes
matters into her own hands and decides
to rescue their daughter from the
clutches of the creatures being an
animal specialist she understands that
chemicals and fire can effectively keep
the animals away and so can her plot
armor with this knowledge in mind she
douses herself with the chemicals
creates a makeshift fire torch using
gasoline and grasps a garden Fork before
heading into the water tank as she
enters the cavern she dispenses the
chemicals into the water to ward off the
monsters upon venturing deeper Jules
discovers her daughter thankfully
unharmed just then she becomes aware of
several other creatures returning to
their nest prompting her to use fire as
her weapon this momentarily scares them
away and using this opportunity Jules
instructs her daughter to head towards
the exit soon after she runs out of
gasoline leaving her with no alternative
but to make her Escape at one point
Jules is attacked by one of the
creatures which drags her beneath the
water nonetheless she bravely fights it
and even manages to kill it by thrusting
the gardening Fork into it after a while
the mother and daughter successfully
exit the water tank and Jules closes the
lid before the creature emerges out
following this Jules leads Reya and
Archie to the police car from where she
retrieves a gun wasting no time she
returns to get banned Jules uses all of
her strengths to carry her husband and
bring him to the car however the
situation intensifies when they spot a
creature perched on the roof of the car
in this crucial moment Jules delivers a
fatal gunshot that penetrates the
creature's brain and then they drive
away with all of this struggle the
family finally manages to flee the scene
upon reaching a safe distance Jules
pulls over and takes some time to regain
her composure the movie ends as they
drive back to the city subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching